all right let's get to our five
headlines
[Music]
number one here the daily wire reports
kenosha prosecutors have dropped the sex
assault charges against jacob blake
following a plea agreement um blake
pleaded guilty now jacob blake of course
he was the uh
he's the the man in kenosha who was
shot by police officers as he was as
police officers were called to the scene
he was allegedly
harassing um a woman who also had
accused him of
of raping her and he had a knife he
assaulted the cops he tried to get into
a car
not his car he tried to get into the
woman's car uh with his kids in there
they tried to stop him they told him to
stop
he reached into the car and then they
shot so that was the recap on that
but he had these sex assault charges uh
again the woman
whose house he was at had accused him of
sexual assault
now prosecutors are dropping those
charges
as part of a plea agreement right blake
pleaded guilty to two counts of
disorderly conduct in order to
get the third degree sexual assault
charge dropped
blake told judge brian schroeder
honestly your honor though i plead
guilty to this i don't consider myself
to be guilty i pretty much took this
opportunity to get to see my children
quicker
blake also said he did not sexually
assault the woman making the allegations
against him blake's attorney
said dropping the charge meant
prosecutors were acknowledging that
ultimately the state could not prove it
in court
uh walworth county district attorney
zeke weidenfeld
told the outlet that the sexual assault
charge was dropped in part because the
accuser refused to cooperate with
prosecution
yeah well of course she refused to
cooperate
and the fact that they didn't that they
didn't have evidence to prove in court
does not at all mean it didn't happen
these are very we have to keep
remember this these are extremely
credible charges against jacob blake
the reason why they're extremely
credible is because
his accuser called police the morning
that this
incident happened she said that jacob
blake broke into her window at like 6
a.m on a like a sunday morning
and walked into a room where she was
sleeping and sexually assaulted her
and then stole her keys her car in a
credit card and left
she she called 9-1-1 and she was
trembling and crying she was still in
her you know in her nightgown
and they came and they saw her there
crying and
obviously traumatized um
i would call that an extremely credible
accusation this is this isn't one of
those accusations somebody comes out of
the woodwork
woodwork you know 30 years later this is
at the moment calling police this is
what happened to me
uh she's not cooperating okay of course
she's not cooperating
her alleged abuser who by the way she
says
has been abusing her for years not just
that one time
for years she said um and he's been
lionized
canonized by the media by the democrat
party
the the potential new president of the
united states
went and met with jacob blake's family
and jacob blake himself
and was singing his praises afterwards
so all of the most powerful people
matt put yourself in this woman's
position
uh assuming that her allegations are
true which i absolutely believe her
believe all women no we don't believe
all women i believe this woman because
the allegations are credible
put yourself in her position you are
viciously assaulted by this man
and now and and then a few months later
he comes steals your keys
you're trying to protect him from you
know your kids uh
gets himself shot in the after
assaulting police
and now all the most powerful voices in
society are coming his defense and
saying he's a great guy
he's a great father even
what is she supposed to do she comes out
and
tries to get this guy locked away
um she's gonna be worried for her own
safety she's gonna be worried about uh
about you know being dragged through the
mud so you you you can definitely see
where she's coming from there
but where are the feminists on this
this this is something where you know
you would think feminists would come out
and come to this woman's
defense i haven't heard anything
and we have seen this whether it's with
jacob blake george floyd
you know there have been at least three
or four cases just the last few months
of blm making martyrs and heroes and
and canonizing uh men who have
abused women in horrible ways
and those women are silenced nobody
talks about them nobody cares about them
feminists not coming to their defense
because feminists are of course
disingenuous phonies
in almost every single case
number two governor cuomo speaking of
disingenuous phonies was on with george
stephanopoulos
who by the way stephanopoulos is
apparently lobbying to be alex trebek's
replacement that's another update here
i mean he's not lobbying cuomo i don't
think andrew cuomo makes that decision
but
he's lobbying to get on jeopardy be the
new replacement for for jeopardy talk
about a talk about a step down in
quality i mean
you go from the most likable guy in
america
to one of the most insufferable goobers
in america
that is that's a very steep drop in
quality
losing trebek and ending up with this
guy it's like remaking a john wayne
movie
and casting like i don't know kate
mckinnon in his role or something which
i don't want to give hollywood ideas
that sounds like something they would
actually do anyway here's uh here's
cuomo talking to george stephanopoulos
and the potential of a vaccine coming
out soon
he doesn't seem very happy about it
oddly enough here he is
we were talking yesterday about the
importance of vaccine distribution in
the next
two months what do you make of this news
uh well
it's it's good news bad news george the
good news is
the pfizer tests look good and we'll
have a vaccine shortly the bad news is
that it's about two months before joe
biden takes
over and that means this administration
is going to be implementing a vaccine
plan
you have two months and we can't let
this vaccination plan go
forward the way the trump administration
is designing it
because biden can't undo it two months
later we'll be in the midst of it
and i'm going i've been talking to
governors across the nation about that
uh how can we shape the trump
administration vaccine plan to fix it
or stop it uh before it does damage yeah
the only
thing may be surprising about any of
this
is just how utterly transparent these
people are being
andrew cuomo is not even trying to hide
it he does not want donald trump getting
credit
for this vaccine he does not want this
coming out on on trump's watch
doesn't want it seems to me he would
rather have people die
just so trump doesn't get the credit
utterly transparent
and speaking of being transparent mark
seagraves of
nbc 4 in washington reports quote dc
mayor
bowser and her staff attended joe
biden's victory speech in wilmington
on saturday delaware is on the mayor's
list of high-risk states which would
require quarantine after returning
bowser's staff says the trip was
essential travel
exempted under mayor's order essential
travel
going to a victory speech at another
state
so you can you know shake hands and hug
and celebrate
that's essential travel now
but mayor bowser just joins a long list
of uh democrat mayors and they have
really all been democrats
democrat mayors disregarding their own
rules and saying oh no i get to
i get to be an exception to this i've
got to tell you
just making up the rules as they go
along
democrats with with the chronovirus
regulations
they remind me a lot of my own kids
in maybe more ways than one but they
remind me of my own children or
they remind me of children in general
but my own kids you know
i play a game with them and they make up
rules as they go
very conveniently like i'm playing tag
with my kids
and they just decide that whatever tree
they're standing next to oh this is base
i'm safe here
that's what the democrats are doing with
the chronovirus restrictions they they
can say oh no i forgot to tell you that
if you're if you're go yeah no you're
not supposed to travel but
if you're going to a victory speech for
joe biden then um did we not put that in
the rules i meant to
are we meant to put in the rules that's
an exception
this is something that people have
liberals have have never understood or
at least have acted like they don't
understand
one of the the primary objections to the
cronovirus restrictions
it's it's not just that they're onerous
though that they are and that is an
objection
but what makes it worse what makes it
untenable
and intolerable and especially
tyrannical
is that they are arbitrary and that they
are not
consistently applied to everyone that is
the real problem
if these restrictions were put in place
and everybody was expected to follow
them
and no exceptions were made and we're
not making exceptions for blm
rioters and people who are dancing the
streets because of uh
joe biden supposedly has won the
presidency and we're not making
exceptions so that the mayor of chicago
can go and get her
her hair done or that nancy pelosi can
and we're not making exceptions for bill
de blasio in new york
everybody follows it i would still
object
but it wouldn't be nearly as oppressive
then we would be objecting on the
grounds that this is just a bad strategy
uh it's you know it's not the right way
to approach this i mean we would still
be strenuously objecting
but what what what makes it infuriating
and what makes it oppressive is the
arbitrariness of it
and the double standards triple
standards quadruple standards the
standards keep changing by the
by the second all right number four if
you want to see what real courage looks
like
here it is look at this footage here blm
protesters marching
in michigan um i don't know if these are
protesters now or
revelers if they're celebrating i don't
know but they're they're marching
this was on i think saturday and this is
what you see now you see these diners
at a restaurant preemptively giving the
black power fist
so they don't get yelled at uh and then
and then there's this whole this this
old guy here who's i don't know what
he's doing he's raising the roof
that's not the black power symbol he's
he's raising the roof
okay a little bit behind the times with
his with his gestures
that's all right um oh no this is this
isn't courage i'm sorry i use the wrong
word this is the exact opposite of
courage
also notice how almost all these people
are white here
all the people sitting at the tables
almost everyone in the crowd all bunch
of white people
virtue signaling by giving the black
power symbol to each other
look i understand you don't want a a mob
descending on you when you're trying to
eat your brunch or whatever you're
eating
but at a certain point you have to have
a little bit of courage grow a little
bit of a spine
number five checking in now with the
great journalistic publication jezebel
uh my producer sent me this blame him
not me apparently the new adaptation of
the witches
is facing backlash because the villain
has a disability
and that's that's uh that's a problem
the article says warner brothers has
apologized after receiving criticism
over their depiction of anne hathaway's
grand witch character
in their new adaptation of uh rual
doll's book
the witches yes it is pronounced ruel by
the way not roll
in the movie hathaway's character is
which i just learned yesterday i'm not
gonna pretend like i knew it before
in the movie hathaway's character is
missing fingers making it appear as
though she has the limb difference
ectrodactyly commonly known as split
hand
this falls into a harmful pattern of
giving villainous characters physical
disabilities perpetuating the oppressive
idea
that people with disabilities are scary
or somehow less moral than people
without disabilities
the vice president of communications at
respectability an organization that
advocates for people with disabilities
also called out the film's decision to
associate disability with evil
characters
in this case even choosing to add a limb
difference that was not a part of doll's
original story
unfortunately this representation in the
witches teaches kids that limb
differences are hideous or something to
be afraid of
what type of message does this send to
children with limb differences
according to a spokesperson of for
warner brothers the studio was deeply
saddened that their depiction of the
characters in the witches might have
upset people with disabilities
but then listen to their statement they
said in adapting the original story
we worked with designers and artists to
come up with a new interpretation of the
cat-like claws that are described in the
book
it was never the intention for viewers
to feel that the fantastical non-human
creatures
were meant to represent them is it just
me or is wander brothers throwing a
little bit of shade here as the kids
would say
maybe it's wishful thinking or
projection but i'm picking up on some
serious
sarcasm in their in their statement
which i like
at any rate if this is offensive then
the penguin
in batman must be really traumatic
though you never know with that one
whether the penguin is offensive on this
basis
or maybe because he's appropriating from
avian culture
who really knows but i am glad we're
having this conversation because i've
always been disturbed by
uh the villains who wear glasses as a
member of the visually impaired
community
vic vic victim as a member of that
community and also as a member of
the facial hair community i'm extremely
distressed
by villains who wear glasses have facial
hair a lot of times
um for example look at this jim carrey's
portrayal of dr robotnik
in the recent uh sonic the hedgehog film
great film by any other measure
but you can see there he's got glasses
and he's got a mustache
and when i see this it's almost as if
the makers of the film
are trying to give the impression that
anyone with glasses and facial hair is
probably hatching a dastardly plot
to kill a magical hedgehog this is a
stereotype that i have carried with me
for years every time i walk down the
street people are shouting like hey
catch any hedgehogs today you loser ha
and they high-five each other
i run away crying it happens every day
so i'm glad that jezebel is calling
attention to this issue it is
very important hey you uh yeah
you you're right you right there hit the
subscribe button right now
do it do it right now i thank you for
your compliance it's
somewhat appreciated